[Musique]
oh
c'était bruyant défraîchi les murs épais
san l'un de graffitis et il y avait une
odeur d'alcool dans les couloirs ça
c'est la cité dans laquelle j'ai grandi
seul avec ma mère pour s'en sortir ma
mère' cumulé de nombreux jobs jour et
nuit et comment il avait eu la chance
d'aller à l'école ou de travailler dans
un domaine précis elle composait avec ce
qu'elle avait son intelligence sa force
de caractère et son courage
et puis un jour malgré les difficultés
elle a décidé de recueillir samuel un
jeune garçon de la cité dans l'alcool et
la drogue
elle ne pouvait pas laisser gâcher sa
vie comme ça alors elle a pris samuel
sous son aile et le week-end même quand
elle n'avait pas le temps elles trouver
quand même un moment de nous faire
pratiquer nos devoirs ensemble et puis
un jour quand samuel aller mieux et
qu'il a entrepris un bep elle a refait
la même chose pour un autre garçon ben
et une autre fille vanessa elle a laissé
parler son intelligence intuitive parce
qu'elle savait au fond d'elle qu'elle
pouvait est arrivé et que samuel lui
pouvait réussir aujourd'hui samuel est
entrepreneur dans le btp
ben chef d'entreprise dans l'aviation et
vanessa éducatrice colère fascinant pour
une femme qui n'est pas là l'école n'est
ce pas
sonne sur la planète ont pas la chance
d'aller à l'école est-ce que cela fait
d'eux des personnes m'en intelligente
pour autant non qu'est ce que
l'intelligence alors vous allez me dire
les notes les tests depuis l'école
les diplômes je ne sais pas mais ce que
je sais c'est que je ne serai
certainement pas devant vous aujourd'hui
si j'avais basé ma vie sur des notes à
l'école je veux devenir femme d'affaires
et travailler aux états unis
la conseillère d'orientation qui me
reçoit l'iman dossier et elle éclate de
rire mademoiselle aco si vous n'avez pas
un niveau vous ne parlez pas anglais
vous n'avez pas les notes et en plus
vous avez fait l
personnellement je pense que vous
devriez plutôt opté pour une carrière de
vendeuse dans une librairie
j'étais dévastée
comment cette personne pouvait définir
ma vie choisir pour moi alors que mon
coeur c'est exactement ce qu'il veut et
ce qu'il veut
et puis plus tard j'ai compris la
conseillère d'orientation n'utiliser en
fait qu'une partie de son intelligence
ben oui ça logique elle ne parlait pas
et ne se basait pas non sur mes volontés
mes patients mais désire mais volonté
rien
elle se baser uniquement sur des faits
et des chiffres pour mieux évaluer ce
qui me ramène à vous dire que de nos
jours dans nos sociétés occidentales
nous avons mis sur un piédestal le mot
intelligence nous avons décidé
d'identifier les individus en fonction
de leurs titres nous avons les yeux qui
brillent d'admiration lorsque quelqu'un
nous parle de ses diplômes
ou qu'ils utilisent un langage savant et
compliqué
résultat ce type de pensée commune et
venus influencer notre intelligence et
l'intelligence collective
pire encore nous faire remettre en
question de nos propres intelligence et
pourtant
on sera plus séduits par quelqu'un qui
nous dit j'ai fait sciences po
et moins séduit par quelqu'un qui nous
dira qu'il a un bébé
pour ma part je souhaite qu'on sorte du
carcan habituel qui dit que si j'ai de
bonnes notes à l'école je suis forcément
intelligent parce qu'il est possible que
dans votre vie vous vous soyez 10 ou
qu'on vous ai dit que vous n'êtes pas
intelligent
l'intelligence logico mathématique et
linguistique oui certes mais alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait de l'intelligence
musicale intra personnel
interpersonnelles spatiale kinesthésique
visuels pour moi l'intelligence
ce n'est pas l'école pascal inverse du
qi le quotient intellectuel dont tout le
monde parle à l'école nous avons aussi
le qu e le quotient émotionnel le
quotient émotionnel vous rambo au
travail il vous donne la confiance en
vous il vous rend loyal ouverts au
changement
pour ma part j'ai choisi le quotient
émotionnel à 18 ans lorsque je suis
parti à 18 km de chez moi j'avais soif
de pouvoir travailler autre chose au
pouvoir à prendre différemment
donc je suis allé au canada dernière de
la classe au lycée en france aux
premières de la classe à l'université au
canada pourquoi parce qu'au canada on
étudie de façon linéaire où vous avez
accès à votre professeur et vous pouvez
poser des questions je vous avais une
certaine liberté qui n'existe pas en
france
aujourd'hui je fait mentir cette
conseillère d'orientation oui je suis
intelligente et oui je peux réussir en
tant que femme d'affaires aux états unis
parce que j'ai créé deux structures une
école au canada et une école aux états
unis qui permettent à des jeunes qui
sortent du scolaire traditionnel pour
pouvoir travailler sur leur intelligence
et leur réussite et je rêve d'un monde
dans lequel on duplique ça
ça va permettre à des jeunes de pouvoir
se retrouver davantage
ça va permettre de travailler avec des
individus en fonction de leur type de
personnalité de leur permettre un cadre
d'apprentissage qui va pouvoir les
propulser je rêve d'une école libre et
respectueuse de chacun dans laquelle on
peut jouer au baby-foot dormir nagé son
envie une école qui puisse permettre aux
individus de pouvoir travailler
différentes formes d'intelligence et que
ces personnes là soit heureuse et
épanouie et non soumise à des critères
de la société et si j'avais écouté la
conseillère d'orientation
je vous promets je serai certainement
une personne très malheureuse
aujourd'hui et à linverse je sais que
vous connaissez certainement qui sont
positifs et qui grâce à leurs maux grâce
à leur positivité peut permettre à des
gens de s'en sortir parce qu'en fait la
réalité c'est quoi la réalité c'est que
tout le monde ici ce soir peut réussir
il peut aider quelqu'un il peut inspirer
quelqu'un à pouvoir aller de l'avant
parce que quiconque veut peut réellement
faire sortir le meilleur de lui pour le
donner à quelqu'un d'autre ce qui me
ramène à vous dire que ce n'est pas
votre vos mots simplement c'est pas
votre intelligence c'est pas vos
diplômes qui font tous aujourd'hui c'est
votre volonté de réussir pour vous et
pour les autres qui font que vous êtes
des héros niveau note niveau diplôme
niveau 2 ctres je vous remercie
[Musique]